siano geni amicizia team anno di
università rivelano due ragazze che
erano molto molto sport da vera facevano
schifo sono sentita pagine la torcia
sono adesso brucia testine è uno schifo
ciò crea tantissime l'atto di de amicis
e vendicarsi a fine anno a ciampi e nel
bagno stima dei meriti delle ragazze si
è regalato volevo fare anche io con la
mia ex consilina e che ora pare faccia
molto bene alla pelle ricordare ma
davvero si sei fatto di questa è una
visione di vacanza decisamente diversa
dalla mia
scatta la rissa miei confronti cenni
quasi picchiata perché i ragazzi tornano
a casa con la candida in bocca ecco
questa è una cosa che avrei fatto io
allegri ha voglia di esenzione la faccia
e mi ha avuto delle vendette che magari
ti ricordi particolari divertente con un
ragazzo che era fissato per la
tecnologia praticamente ci lasciamo
perché lui si comporta male con me
attivo con lui e io me ne sono andato di
casa
e visto che lui faceva tutto al computer
e non aveva a casa penne o quale abbiamo
portato tutto io e io ho portato via
tutte le prende tutti i quaderni così
lui non potrà più scrivere
mi sono sentita 9 ogni singolo per ogni
singolo foglio licei doveva salvare la
spesa non fai dove scriverlo cacchio 6
crude non so se ti ricordi mi aiuta
tutti a farla parliamo di qualche anno
bambino sono in 7000 13 io avevo
litigato in modo molto pesante fondo uno
dei miei migliori amici a causa della
sua fidanzata che mi hanno mandato a
quel paese senza nessun motivo e noi non
ha fatto assolutamente niente
io per vendicarmi una sera ha mandato
messaggi a te dice il thun e richiamato
ciccio c'è stata nella storia e gli ho
detto in diretta nazionale sulla faglia
che era concesso quindi la mia vendetta
è stata dire a tutta italia e se con
dice bravo complimenti
ti senti un po non conosco questa volta
non l'ho mai sentita la voce non ho mai
lavorato per radio deejay
non ho un canale su youtube palazzo di
via e attento perché ti faccio sparire
tutte le belle ragazze
no ti prego non venga pace ha
praticamente questo nemico chiamano
chiamiamolo ottava con la saga si è
stato con la sua ragazza per quattro
anni perché noi fatto sapere che la sua
casa rotativa ma cosa ha fatto più
utilizzando il pigiama della sua ex
ragazza
praticamente al pigiama nella sua ex
ragazza e quando gliela dovuto di
restituire non l'hanno fatto
ma questo gesto di fecondazione del
pigiama che il nome triste pippo che in
questa storia
così la serie d'oro morire o e la casa
ad un certo punto oggi da questa vicenda
stanza che urlava notte senza avere la
possibilità vedo questa signora dentro
la piscina i capelli asciutti gli utili
da soli e truccata per la forte rabbia
che mi aveva dato le note precedenti
cosa faccio mi metto a sbattere con i
piedi fortissimi rasata tutta perché io
odio odio le persone così io odio odio
rosa resta che non massimo aggressivo io
a un albero
ciao a sapri alti i capelli lunghi fino
al ginocchio
a un certo punto dice mia madre non mi
ha mai più mai l'eccesso termica pelli
arriva un giorno e ci chiediamo che io
che faccio parrucchiere i dico toglimi
tutto se ne ho fatto avere i capelli di
proporsi per accorgersi miei capelli
sono per vendicarmi teniamo altre il suo
testo musica altro tutto ciò che però ci
sta se invece la pur di togliermi i
pidocchi ma un giorno la benzina noi
casa dei capelli fino al ginocchio alza
quando ti siedi l'ho fatto a cambri
le ascelle con le generali abili rubate
peggiori che sarà fatta da un mio amico
annuncio amico in pratica non i delatori
brutto e lui perché vita ha preso il suo
appello se lo infila sono così ogni
volta che questo ragazzo perché è la
belle realtà sarà stanco
ciao visite per vendicarsi cosa faresti
impazzisco gli alibi lo faccio per
vendicarmi qualche rotolino frequentato
con questo ragazzo ha un po più grande
di mani mi piaceva un sacco stravedevo
per noi ciò che lui così da un giorno
all altro morto
ci piace che si ritira ovviamente dopo
pianti con una la mia guida replica
passaggio fino a qua sia stato quando ho
deciso di rifarsi di nuovo significa
ovviamente fobia candle detto la
vendetta sta nel fatto che la mia a per
vendicarne vero spata musulmani né
l'islam sotto che sia bene la vendetta
che nodi casuale mi sa bene ripari non
so se è stato acquistato mio genio
questa ragazza non ti preoccupare adesso
di vendita ringraziarmi
senti il ragazzo di questa tua amica che
farà un torto vendicata anche questa
ragazza che aveva grandissima colpa di
fare col ragazzo che mi piaceva io per
questo motivo quindi dalla finestra
della mia classica che ho sputato il
motorino che ha parcheggiato lì sotto
motorino sempre subito giù ed ha quindi
come capitò antiche monete che tutto
sono io sono proprio molto pericolosi
non avrei dovuto un ragazzo mio amico
così per scherzo mi aveva appeso ad un
albero con una corda ai neo peluche come
sembra finalmente fosse implicato che ci
siamo dati nota altri quindi siccome
dono nella pure vele cavalli è passato
un intero pomeriggio con accordi neri
canone e mette dentro un barattolo e poi
lasciato nella sua tenda che nascose
hanno fatto entrare e poi coniglio che
il ho chiuso dentro ho lasciato per un
panino e meglio dio la piaga d'egitto
sei le locuste per fa più pensa alla
pazienza scientifica si visto
l'orsacchiotto e merida meno ridando in
un lambro ha ripreso lo sa che 8 euro
tocca
un ragazzo siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video e se complice ormai di
tutto quello che abbiamo sentito no e
sapete che non abbiamo fatto se il fili
tutto quello che ho ricevuto perché
alcune cose erano al limite ed è molto
creativi e continuate a farvi sapere nei
commenti qui sotto a parte i quali sono
state vostre esperienze con le vendette
ma allo stesso tempo continuate a
suggerirmi dei termini da buttata che mi
piace un sacco alle vostre idee
a me personalmente ha divertito un sacco
grazie a cannes the cloud e naturalmente
perché 6 grazie governo perché non
dormirà stanotte dovuto odore di ridire
averti qua per un altro canoni dai
facciamolo amputazione prima voti più
difficilmente sarà miss chiudere
iscrivetevi attivate le notifiche
commentate commentate commentate visto
in cui anche un problema del credito
grazie così volta mi chiamo così ciao